you see what deuce has become to the  world how does it make you feel are you  a little uncomfortable with how famous  deuce is now yeah extremely  uncomfortable he didn't ask for that i  asked for it by being who i am it comes  with the job but there's a lot of things  that i have to like think about and  worry about as he gets older that you  know makes me a little uneasy like the  thought of him going to school maybe i  need to send like a security guard to  school maybe not being a classroom would  be outside the classroom and that's not  normal when i was growing up my mom she  would ask me where am i going who's  going to be there send me the address  let me know and i just like mom like  relax i'm gonna be all right she's  always telling me like you won't  understand until you have one of your  own the thought of not being able to be  there to protect them is a frightening  feeling with social media and everything  i'm trying to navigate that the right  way as much as possible